a high-profile poker player pled guilty
after he was accused of sex crimes and
this is a case with many twists and
turns
it is a story the i-team first broke
last year vanessa murphy talked with a
poker player today
and has this latest update
[Music]
raymond davis spoke with the i team from
a las vegas jail last november
have you paid underage girls for sexual
acts
never never i had i have been to massage
parlors i admit that
uh i have uh picked up girls off
craigslist i miss
that but i have never never in my life
paid a girl
an underage woman girl for sex davis is
now a free man
the high profile poker player is active
again on social media and with a group
he started
real grinders on october 6 davis pleaded
guilty to felony coercion
and misdemeanor contributing to the
delinquency of a minor
metro police say an underage girl
claimed davis paid her for oral sex at
his home on several occasions after they
met on facebook
and at one point her friend said he paid
them to take a shower while he watched
through the plea deal nine charges
alleging he's a sexual predator would be
dropped
court records reveal he gets credit for
time served and could go to prison if he
doesn't stay out of trouble
from day one it has been total bias
against me
the case has been complicated to say the
least the warrant for davis was issued
in september of 2016.
he wasn't taken into custody until a
traffic stop in april of 2019
despite him frequently showing his
locations on social media
when the i-team reached out to metro
police in november to find out why it
took so long to arrest him
our question wasn't answered and davis's
bond was originally set at 25 thousand
dollars which he posted
but after he tried representing himself
made allegations about the judge and
prosecutor
and acted erratically in court his bond
was set at half a million dollars
judge jacqueline bluth referred to
inappropriate behavior by davis
three previous felony convictions and
more
now the case may be wrapping up but just
a few days after he agreed to the plea
deal
in this lengthy facebook post davis
continued to profess his
innocence vanessa murphy 8 news now